you can keep doing what you're doing
you're going to keep getting what you're
getting it's the same as somebody trying
to lose weight saying I want to keep
eating the same diet and you expect the
outcome to look different and it's just
not true you have to confront reality
and a lot of entrepreneurs are
delusional a lot of times that delusion
takes control and they believe the false
statements no one can do it like I can
do it I'm irreplaceable et cetera et
cetera every single human on planet
Earth is replaced in 100 years the
likelihood is that if you were doing it
and you're also doing other things then
somebody doing full-time what you're
doing will be better than you are